we want to provide more services that
help people to be as healthy and as well
as they can be and prevent them from
developing health problems this means
services that respond quickly when you
contact them for help it also means
having services that support people in a
holistic way
this means supporting people with things
like housing employment and relationship
problems as well as their emotional and
physical well-being
it includes services that support people
to lead healthier lifestyles for example
to help people stop smoking and lose
weight
we want to give people the skills and
knowledge to be able to help themselves
this is so that they can make healthy
choices lead active lifestyles and reach
up for help and support at the earliest
opportunity
to make this happen we need to make sure
that information about services reaches
as many people as possible
we also want to make sure that services
are welcoming non-judgmental and
sensitive to people's needs and
ambitions
some residents need extra help and
support to access services and
activities that can assist them to
manage their health
in these situations we want people to
know what is available nearby
how to access it and to feel able to
connect into it no matter who they are
or where they live
the gp will often be the first port of
call when someone needs help
yet help can be accessed via other
routes too
our voluntary community
faith and social enterprise sector
partners play a vital role providing a
range of services that support people to
manage their fiscal and mental wellbeing
helping to build resilience and greater
independence